[Musique]
j
je voulais vous présenter un délit qui
m'a le plus ému et plus emballés de
cette rentrée littéraire la jeune fille
qu'on appelle de tanguy viel qui est un
livre qui m'a vraiment bouleversée
l'histoire de max qui est le chauffeur
d'un maire d'une petite ville au bord de
mer qui va demander en fait à celui ci
s'il peut trouver un boulot et un
logement pour sa fille laura le maire va
accepter elle va trouver donc une un
logement un boulot qui est pas forcément
des plus glorieux et puis surtout il va
demander en fait une certaine faveur
alors à et laura elle va se sentir
obligé d'accepter un roman excellemment
bien écrit fort qui laisse pas indemne
je présente la carte hostens à un roman
d'anne berest l'autrice va faire le
déroulé de la vie de ses ancêtres les
grands oncles et tantes qui ont été
déportés à auschwitz on part d'un point
de départ qui est une carte postale où
les noms de ses grand oncles et tantes
et leurs parents sont notés et qui
arrive dans la boîte aux lettres
familial ça va devenir une sorte de
quête perpétuelle du sens et de son
récit familial puisque en fait elle
n'avait aucune idée de ce qui s'était
passé une recherche personnelle très
très forte émouvant et touchant jusqu au
bout
[Musique]
tu représentes trou story un roman
américain de 4 p tit qui se lit comme un
très bon polar deux époques 99-2000
19,99 on va suivre une bande de jeunes
qui ont 17 ans le but dans leur vie
c'est de faire des soirées les plus
folles possible les plus dingues et puis
un soir il y en a deux qui raccompagne
une jeune fille chez elle
je suis et commettre zerka la fumée elle
a bu elle est quasiment pas consciente
on ne sait pas du tout ce qui s'est
passé mais par contre quand égaler les
deux garçons reviennent ils sont
titillés par les autres de la bande
forcément il s'est passé quelque chose
on fait un bond de 20 ans dans le temps
et là on reprend certains personnages
qu'on a vu au début et notamment cette
jeune fille et qu'est ce qui s'est passé
qu'est ce que c'est c'est paroles
lancées en l'air ont eu comme impact sur
leur vie et sur ses vingt ans passés
c'est absolument génial mais c'est un
roman qui m'a construit récents
formidable
[Musique]